Good evening to
everyone I am a Muslim by
profession from Central Africa I have been
leading people to go to the prayer room
and to go to the prayer room
and then this little boy he came and went to the prayer
room and now he said he wanted to discuss
something with me one
I opened up to him he tried to convince me to become a
Muslim the good thing for
me
and I asked him why do you do something good
for
me he said then I should try it and never
regret and I told him I listened
to the speakers
his
Kalam is the
best so I was a
Muslim
mashallah
badar
yay Muslim mal
mashallah that age is never a barrier
and I know that more than 10% of you may not have
spoken to a non Muslim and this young boy I
think his age may be six years seven years
mashallah 12 years not even in
his teens has convinced us  Brother yes
Mashallah from Cameron brother are you
accepting Ilam out of your free will yes
sir am I even forcing you no no no no one is
forcing me sir Mashallah it is free will do
you believe that there is one God yes one do you
believe that Prophet Mohammad is
the last and final messenger yes inshallah
so I just say in Abiq and you can repeat
inshallah and then inshallah I
sish ashad ad Allah Allah ilaha ila Allah illa waad ana Ana Mohammad Mohammad abad ab ras ras I be witness I be
witness that there is no God there is no God but
Allah
and Prophet Mohammad is his messenger
and he is his messenger and he is his swan
and swt Mashallah Mashallah you Muslim
Mashallah Allah do you and I pray
Allah Subhan Taala
that may he guide you and may
Allah grant you Jannah and I pray also that may he
Youngster Mashallah and I
request Badar meet new Muslim to become a Muslim
and we will help them by giving them information about
Islam. I am
most welcome to our
next question from sister.
My sister is a sister and she also wants to
make her
Shahada Mashallah and then the question answer session
turn into a Shahada session. Yes sister are you
convinced about
Islam sister what is your name yes I am
my name is Eddie from Philippines are you
convinced about Islam sister yes I am is
anyone forcing you to accept Islam
is anyone forcing you to accept Islam is your
free will know it is my free will do you
believe there is one God yes I do
believe do you believe that Prophet Mohammad is
a messenger of God yes I do believe
inshallah I say in Arabic and you can
repeat sister inshallah
Ashad  Ashad I shu Allah Allah ilaha ilaha illallah illallah wadu ana Ana
Mohammed Mohammed Abdu Abdu wa
varas I bear witness that there is no god
but Allah
and Prophet
Mohammed is the Messenger the
Messenger and servant of Allah and the
servant of Allah so Mashallah sister you become
Muslim Alhamdulillah
and I pray to Allah Subhana ta'ala that may he
grant you
Jannah and if you have any queries any question about
Islam you are most free
to ask the local organization and you can go to
our website
www.net and surely you can contact the local
people here for having more knowledge of Islam you
can read the books and I pray to Allah
Subhana wa ta'ala that inshallah
to guide you and to get Janangale